- I'm so sorry I can't hug.
I get in trouble.
(audience cheers)
We're getting closer to hugs.
I feel it.
I feel as though we're
getting closer to hugs.
Maybe not.
I don't know.
Can he sit there?
No. Yes? Yep. Nope. Yep.
- I'll come here.
Sorry.
- You can sit closer.
- Wow.
- I'll go to this one.
- [Stage Crew] Same one.
- Same one?
That's where I went the first time.
- Oh my God.
Did y'all know that we were going to play,
what's that game we
played in the chair game.
- Musical chairs!
- Musical chairs.
You didn't know, but
that's what's happening.
- [Jenny] They didn't tell us.
- I have a Goldilocks thing I like to do.
Just test every chair when I come out.
- You're like Goldilocks.
You're checking them out. (laughs)
- Yeah. Which bed's softest?
- I love it.
- You'll just fall asleep.
Yeah, take a snooze.
- I wish I could be one
of those people that
falls asleep anywhere.
Can you do that?
- Now, I can.
- [Kelly] Well, yes, now you can.
You're a mom!
Congratulations. Yeah! (audience claps)
- Thank you.
- And congratulations, you
just got married, right?
- I did, I did.
I just got married about a month ago.
- Oh my gosh. Congratulations.
(audience claps)
That's so cool.
So what is it like,
married life at your house?
You like it so far?
- I like it.
I like it.
I'm a born romantic.
I'm very suited to it, I think.
Yeah, we got married,
we got married on New Year's Eve,
which is a nice.
- [Kelly] That's beautiful.
- Oh, thank you.
- [Kelly] Beautiful, yeah.
- It was my husband's great-grandmother's.
- I was going to say, oh, I love that.
I was like, there's a story there.
That's so beautiful.
- There is. There's a story stere.
- No I just meant, more
than like it's just
a brand new ring he bought.
It looked like beautiful and antique.
- I know.
And now I'm kind of like
I think there's some
banana bread batter also.
It is the kind thing where they're like,
"Will you marry me?"
And you're like, "Yes.
Are you sure you want to give me that?"
- I'm going to ruin this.
- Because you've met me before
and I have the back
of my dress tucked into my underwear.
You know what I mean?
- That's my kind of person.
Wait, so did you get
married at your house?
- Yes.
- Wait, so was that stressful or exciting?
- My best friend told me that
I was surprisingly chill,
which I will brag about on national TV.
- You should.
Most people don't, aren't that way.
- Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I was chill about it.
We only had 23 people.
It was like after many cancellations
and we actually, I mean,
now it just seems like I'm weird,
but we live in my husband's
great-grandmother's house, too.
- Oh my gosh.
I love this.
Everything is you're going to become her.
- I know. I'm just like, wave goodbye.
- Wait, I heard about this though,
because the house,
she used to throw like huge
parties or whatever, right?
Do people have weird dreams?
Did I hear?
- Yes.
- Okay. Okay, what?
- That's what they say.
I mean, my dreams are all weird,
so I'm like I don't know.
It seems normal to me, but yeah.
- Definitely his
great-grandmother haunting you.
- [Jenny] Oh for sure. Yeah.
- Give me my ring back!
(audience laughs)
- Get that banana bread out.
- She's got my ring!
- I heard, did she throw
like crazy fun parties?
- She threw crazy parties there.
Their family calls it the Playhouse.
It's like where they would dance.
And apparently, like throughout the years,
guests who, they come, they stay
and they wake up and they're like,
I had some crazy dreams last night.
- [Kelly] Oh, some crazy good ones?
- Yeah. Crazy party dreams.
- When can I come over?
- Any time you want.